the answer through  regret is action  past regret if you're sitting thinking  about how great the past used to be  the answer is to do something because  you're not excited about what you're  doing right now  you're bored you're not excited about  what you're doing right now and so you  stay stuck the answer is action if  you're excited about what you're doing  right now and you're taking some kind of  action you're not thinking about the  past anymore  same thing for future fear if you're  afraid of what could be in the future  and that's where you spend your time  thinking it also means you're not taking  action you're not doing anything  the answer is action to do to create and  that focus you back on the present  instead of what may happen in the future